JT is with us in Norfolk Virginia hi JT
how are you hey Dave better than I
deserve
what's up hey so my question was living
I guess you'd call it like a debit
lifestyle on credit and like really what
the the question was like I like now
we're talking about getting like a high
rewards credit card and using it as a
debit card and I was one I know you
don't like credit cards but is it
what kind of is that a good idea or is
it that I'm so confused you have a
credit card or you have a debit card you
can't use a credit card like a debit
card you mean you want to get a credit
card and pay it off every month yeah
like use it as like a debit and then
we'll just collect the rewards on it
yeah you can't use a credit card like a
debit card because it doesn't come
directly out of your checking account a
credit card bill at the end of month and
then you pay the bill yeah yes okay I
guess paying the bill like whatever it's
due or just paying the balance on it
whatever really balanced yeah no I would
not do that
I have never met a single millionaire
and I've met thousands of them that said
Dave you know those rewards programs
that's how I made all my money they make
money on those reward programs you
understand that 22 22 trillion trillion
unclaimed airline miles Wow unclaimed
that's enough to send you and 20,000 of
your friends to Pluto and back and this
is all people who did what you did now
here's the problem okay it sounds like
it's perfectly mathematically neutral
but it's a behavior based thing let me
walk you through it cuz it's a great
discussion I love you I love your
question it's a valid question here's
the thing when you feel pain spending
money you spend less all kinds of
studies that do that and really common
sense tells you that okay in other words
if we went to an extreme and we said
every time you spent money we were gonna
shock you
you know you would just quit spending
money right I mean so here's the
spectrum of feeling pain it's called
friction in the marketing world
especially in the digital marketing
world the harder it is the more steps
you have to go through to buy something
on the website that's called friction
the greater the friction the less chance
you're going to close you're gonna stay
in there store and close the transaction
and buy the item on a website you know
what I'm saying yeah so the easiest
version of that will be what Amazon
Prime you just push a button in its home
boom you can even get a little Amazon
thing to sit on your desk and just hit a
button and it will automatically order
stuff right friend of mine had that as
toddler they kept getting a detergent
showing up at their doorstep
like massive amounts of detergent they
couldn't figure out why and the button
was down low enough that the toddler
kept hitting the button and ordering the
detergent so you'd say so that's what
really happens now what happens is
Amazon Prime is so much easier to buy
you spend more does that make sense okay
so the spectrum is cash real $100 bills
laying in front of you is the most
friction of a spending methodology a
payment methodology because the studies
done by Carnegie Mellon with MRI shows
that the pain centers of the brain are
activated when a hundred-dollar bill
leaves your hand and doesn't come back
you have an ouchy moment okay all the
way on the other end of the spectrum
would be Apple pay where you don't even
touch something that you associate with
money you touch only your phone because
you don't emotionally touch her you
don't emotionally associate your phone
with money and so you just do Apple pay
and you just swipe it right boom you buy
stuff just wave your phone over the one
oh and you buy stuff it's magic or you
hit the Amazon Prime button and it's
it's magic or you do PayPal and it's
magic and it's real easy and you're not
touching something handling something
that the brain associates with money so
that's the least friction item where
you're going to spend the most money
does that make sense in the middle then
would be the debit one step in from cash
on pain is the debit card which when use
a debit card you're touching something
that has to do with money because you
only use that card for a money
transaction the brain knows that in the
brain activates
and then you also know automatically
that this is coming right out of your
checking account and so in your mind
you're doing a little math going do I
have any money in my checking account
I'm about to go into overdraft by going
to this restaurant with this debit card
okay so it's got a sense of pain a sense
of reality tied to it because it's tied
to your checking account it's not as
painful as cash but it's one notch in
one more notch in would be the credit
card you're talking about where you're
very disciplined and you're very smart
you're intelligent and you pay off your
credit card every single month and you
get points but now think about the cons
what conversation we've been having all
about friction all about trying to get
you to use of the card with ease and
here's what the mind does it plays
tricks on you and this is why they do it
you say oh I get points back when I buy
something I'm going to buy more right
well let's do the transaction analysis
for a second Discover card gives you 1%
back that means that if you spend
$100,000 of real money Discover card
gives you $1,000 on what planet is that
a path to wealth right not but your
brain says oh I'm getting points I let's
just get a desert I'm getting points
let's get the bigger fluffier one or
whatever it is this is what your brain
does and it causes you to spend more so
all the data says you spend the least
when you're spending cash you spend the
next least with a debit card you will
spend more with a credit card even with
your commitment to pay it off in order
to get the points because also you don't
have to worry about but whether there's
money in your checking account I'll just
pay it off then of the month it's kind
of a kind of a flippant thing in your
brain and then the least amount of
friction the easiest transaction is the
waving of your magic phone your Apple
pay or PayPal or Amazon Prime or stuff
like that none of these things are evil
but what we have to realize as wise
consumers is that they affect our buying
behaviors they affect
much we spend and so if you did your
plan you will spend more on average over
the scope of a year then you will then
you will using a debit card and a lot
more than you would using a cash
transaction another extreme example of
that is the smaller the item by the way
the more the impulse is as you really
aren't you just it's not does its amount
of money doesn't matter so you go up to
the coca-cola machine you go up to the
Coke machine the vending machine in the
hotel right and they now have the little
things you used to have coin slots in
them now they have dollar feeders in
them like they're an ATM and reverse and
you can feed your dollar bill in there
if you can get it to take it it spits it
back out three times you smooth it out
you push it back in there you know the
routine right it's it's it's it's screwy
now the vending machines have a card
reader you can stick your card in there
and buy a coke hole or a bag of chips or
a Pepsi or whatever is your gonna buy
right here's what's interesting the cash
buyers at a hotel vending machine spend
one hundred and seventy eight percent
less than the credit card or debit card
buyer at the vending machine because
once you got that card in there yeah
I'll take chips I'll get a candy bar
I'll get a bottle of water for Mama I'll
get a coke I mean you just load it up
baby you spend four or five times more
one hundred seventy eight percent more
spending not get granted it's just a few
dollars but it illustrates the point
that friction matters whether or not you
feel it because feeding that stupid
dollar bill in there and it comes back
out because it's wrinkled and spit it
you all know what I'm talking about
right thing comes in and out coming to
drive you nuts right that that's you can
aggravate trying to buy something it's
making it hard to buy and the harder
something is to buy the less you spend
now as long as we know that and we can
control those behaviors or we can manage
those behaviors when we accept the risk
associated with those behaviors we're
fine but what I'm trying to do here is
to teach you guys including ujt because
you asked a really fine question thank
you sir for calling in with that
question
it's to teach you
to say that these things are not rolling
around out there on accident all of this
stuff has been researched there's been
focus grouped that they've managed the
behavior they've watched the behavior of
small groups and they know exactly what
their rate of return is on airline miles
on rewards points on all of that they
know what they're gonna make on your use
of the card and if they can get you to
use the car they'll recoup all that and
a bunch more thus their building is
taller than your house this is how this
happened it's not an accidental it's not
an accidental random success story very
intentional great question